I believe in what Patrick's saying but
ultimately I've read the Bible so I know
what's gonna happen and you can fight it
for now but eventually it's going to be
what's gonna happen well once once again
uh there's gonna be control where we
can't fight back which means I think
it's the same no but it just means for
example like in this scenario this world
I want to say conclusion is going to be
one dollar one government one people
and if you go against the agenda you're
out and then once again in the Bible but
like you know Jesus comes back
Antichrist is here and then but once
again I take it as once again looking at
for what it really is and I agree we
should fight from for now but
potentially we can't fight anymore
you know again the the weight of that
argument there's nothing you said I
disagree with nothing I'm a Christian
man yeah so I'm with you there but I
also think about
the conversation lets you say with God
okay and he's looking at you and I I
said all right so listen
if you do believe in God
at one point you were on your knees
praying where life sucked at least for
me I was yeah scar like listen God man
what do you want me to do I'm ready and
then you make some drastic changes to
your life okay let's say you do that and
you pray and then he does what he
introduces new person who introduces you
to person Life Changes you're in a
better financial situation and then
imagine after he introduces to all these
guys to if you believe in God and then
all of a sudden you're like nah man I
did it all myself it wasn't God it was
on me okay you're like no goddess for
weaker people and a boom there's another
fall they're like but God God and God's
like
so I think
that argument you made is also the
reason why many Christians are not
fighting because they're just like
saying well I mean we all know what's
going to happen at the end we all know
what's going to happen at the end we all
do you know the exact date no what if
that's 200 years from now what if it's
100 years from what's 500 what if 50
what if it's two years from now so it
doesn't let you sit and wait no I think
we need to do our part to fight until
that day comes and we don't know what
that date is that should produce a sense
of urgency in the people who have the
ability to do so those who can they
should do the fight if not so many
people will be on the sidelines and who
cares can't do anything about it anyway
kind of like your uh election question
you know the it's a very good argument
he's right I understand that I
understand there's a lot of people that
relate to what he has to say you're not
alone in that argument no but but it's
almost like it was already written it's
already prescribed yeah there's nothing
what I can do why would I go vote why
would I go try to do anything
everything's already written out there
everything's already figured out for me
I'm convinced I'm convinced at this
point the more I'm thinking about this
fresh is in love
because when you're in love you look at
life and like what really matters more
than love you know I just can't wait for
this podcast then to call my girl and go
hang out and you know life changes
I will say this you're you're
um ideals and you're
um
speech today has put a light under my
ass to say you know what until that day
comes I should be putting the work pause
but at the same time it's like you're
right I am right but still what am I
doing right now in the moment you're
right yeah I I'm telling you you're 100
right yeah yeah but you know we don't
have the like you know the the one
argument difference there's so many
things that people would say that I
would never understand I had to really
figure this thing out for example
um you know imagine Myron one day you
are so rich that you don't have to work
a single day for the rest your life
I would sit there and I would think I'm
like what a miserable life yeah to not
have to work my dad is 81 years old he
was just in the hospital for five days
you know we all
this is no one needs to know this but
anyway some he's doing fine right now
but it was almost like done done my dad
this last week we had a big scare
but you know what he's already already
doing today he's already working he
can't help himself right so these
contradictions in life and confusing
statements I'll give you another one
so uh uh first one we said was what hey
imagine if you have all the money in the
world you don't have to work for the
rest of your life right here's another
one that's very annoying you know how
you should live life
what if today on your drive home you get
into an accident and you die
what would you do if you knew you had 30
minutes left so so let me get this
straight for the people that give that
message so you mean to tell me you want
to have me spend the rest of my life as
if I'm gonna die in the next 30 minutes
because if I knew I'm gonna die in the
next 30 minutes I'm not on this podcast
tonight right right hey neither are you
right we're elsewhere you're hanging out
with your mom and dad with your family
yeah you know you're with people that
you love your your new girl you're you
know your Adam's probably out there you
know doing what he's doing but the point
is even that argument yeah it's a
motivational video that goes viral but
it's confusing as for younger
audience yeah so what you're saying is
hey you shouldn't really give that much
work because you should spend time with
the people that you love that's also a
lightweight argument because if I live
that life I'm just going to sit around
do nothing I don't buy that either I
think to me you have to make a list of
people in your life you don't want to
disappoint okay so who do people in your
life you don't want to disappoint for me
it's the man upstairs yeah it's God it's
my four kids it's my wife and the people
that are the most loyal to me I don't
want to disappoint those guys right okay
and quite frankly a part of that on that
list is the men and women who built
America into the greatest country in the
world where have the ability to live the
dream life I just don't want to
disappoint these guys okay
now the selfish life is to say what I
give a if I appoint the you know at
this point these guys are not they're
not that important to me no I don't want
to disappoint these guys I want to come
through for these guys if you have that
mindset then you're living for that
cause I don't know why accidentally all
your selfish dreams also become a
reality if I tell you my life right now
my life doesn't make sense right now I
can't even tell you my life right now
when I have the conversations people
that are calling me people out of my
house every day I'm at my house I'm like
sit sometimes I just sit down like you
know it's crazy who's been at the house
this last two weeks pretty wild who's
been a thousand last two weeks
you guys know this guy at one point in
Japan High School do these guys know I
joined the army at 18 because my plan
was to go 20 years and I would have
retired six years ago at 38 because I
thought I can't ever make more money
than four grand a month I thought four
grand was so much money and then when I
was gonna get out of the army I was
going to be a cop I'm big I'm
intimidating I can be a cop I can impose
myself I don't have a problem with that
and then I'm going to do that for 20
years and I'm going to use my 20 years
military and I'm going to retire 58
years old what a dream that's what I'm
gonna I bought into that dream yeah
small thinking fear base I'm a regular
guy and then all of a sudden I did too
you and I both and look what you're
doing today you know look how you're
putting yourself out there look how much
noise you're making look how much you
get people to be thinking about
different things so I think I think the
part is there's nothing wrong with
pursuing your selfish desires and I
think you need to but if you're by
yourself in a car you're sitting there
saying who do I not want to disappoint
make a list of those people I think
that's gonna produce a a man's man who
doesn't just live for himself we were
doing an index together it's a good
question for you I'm curious to know
what your answer would be with this one
so
um
say we have 10 different types of people
okay I'm actually really curious in my
room what you're going to say to this
question here so what is the best
person's net positive to society okay
you have selfish you have unselfish okay
or selfless right selfless selfish okay
somebody that lives for them and
somebody that lives for others okay
let's split it let's say somebody that's
100 selfish zero percent selfless okay
and let's say somebody that's a hundred
percent selfless
zero percent selfish okay and then let's
go 1090 2080 30 70. what is the right
mixture of contributing to society where
you're a net positive to society you
understand the question I'm asking right
I understand yeah so so for example if
you say well you know it's to be 100
selfless and zero percent selfish let's
actually unpack that if that's you that
means you smell that means you don't
take showers that means you're tough to
be around because you don't care about
yourself everything's about other people
you don't want to be clean you probably
have viruses you probably are you know
because everything's about other people
you're a net negative to society so as
much as we want to say wow that's such a
noble person you're actually not you're
hurting the rest of us if we go the
other side yeah you know what it's best
to be 100 selfish zero percent selfless
believe it or not the 100 selfish is
better to society than 100 selfless as
crazy as it sounds
so then you go well it's good to be 50
50. what is it no to be 50 50. so what
do you think the number is what do you
think that by the way there's no right
answer to this is just talking about it
yeah this open-ended question uh fresh
you want to take it first yeah so uh
going off for like what I've done myself
and what I've seen other uh successful
do and how it worked out for them
uh look at Grant Cardone right you're
selfish at the very beginning but being
selfish led to him
impacting so many lives so using as an
example of myself and other people I
would say
selfish
let's say like 80 percent
self is 20 percent
that's that's that's interesting what
would you say I was literally going to
say the same thing 80 selfish 20
selfless and then as you because here's
the thing if you're selfish right up
front you'll be able to turn that down
and become more selfless as you acquire
more resources knowledge and the ability
to actually become more selfless because
you can help people because you prop
yourself up right by being selfish you
get to where you need to get to and then
once you're in that position of power
then you can start to slowly say okay I
could start to be a little bit more of a
humanitarian here I can go ahead and
start allocating some of these resources
wisdom Etc to others so I can start to
become more selfless now so then you
could drop it down I think you got to
start off damn near 90 10 and then you
can work your way down to an 80 20 70
30. I totally agree with that yeah I
agree you know what's funny yeah so you
said earlier to sit down by yourself
who do you want to not disappoint and
what does life mean to you and I did
that a couple months ago I was sitting
down saying you know what I'm having fun
partying I'm meeting people doing fun
stuff but I'm not adding real value I'm
not actually being a man of means right
because obviously you know we're set up
we have real estate we have good
Investments whatever but what else is
there and that's you know what
I'm being selfish to a point where I'm
being just hedonistic I got a phone call
with a friend of my AMS he said bro
you're off your purpose what are you
really doing and then I said you know
what what can I do right now to add
value and that's what I started the CEO
Network I said you know what I'm gonna
give back to people that support us
don't want to be around us and by
default this community I created bro
like we're doing so much big things just
in less than three months so I think
just having that talk to yourself goes a
long way let me add to that you guys go
ahead yeah well the list that you put
together your family your friends you
you almost talk about your legacy your
forefathers who brought you into this
world I think this is going to be a
little selfish right now I think the one
person that you need to put at the top
of that list is you yourself I think no
matter what we're all sitting there we
have to look each other in the mirror
yourself in the mirror every single day
shout out to Chas Paul and Terry the
saddest thing in life by far is wasted
Talent we all have two different
versions of ourselves we all have the
version who's just lazy and just not
doing stuff and has limited beliefs it
isn't getting done and you have the
other person that's waking up earlier in
the day putting the work in becoming the
best version of themselves I mean it's
the essence of what you do on this
podcast yeah and I think we all have
that issue I mean the the number one
prior one of the main situations that's
uh plaguing the United States right now
is depression how much should how many
people just look in the mirror are not
happy with themselves so this is a
little bit selfish one of the things
that I'm breaking out of my show is from
Pat
encourage you you need to be a leader
you need to have a family you need to
have a kids I'd be a great father I want
that in my life but right now I've been
very selfish rightfully so I'm on that
90 10 path 80 20 path no doubt Myron
yeah but at some point
um the selfish list needs to wane and
being selfless needs to increase and uh
if you don't look in the mirror you're
not happy with yourself you're not like
as much as you want to make other people
happy you can't make everybody happy if
you're not happy yourself 100
dude this is a very good question so I
like this uh I'm gonna put this in the
description uh for the people to see it
he showed me the net positive index NPI
chart uh and it goes here when you're
100 selfish it makes you a criminal
psychopath danger to society uh when
you're 90 10 selfish uh in favor of
selfish you're a narcissist world
revolves around you that's the most
modern day women uh and then at 80 20
you become a solo solopreneur State set
an example of success uh but bad at
duplicating and then at 70 30 it looks
like you become king maker and a driver
and then it looks like a synergist slash
great team at 60 40. yeah so it starts
to become more and more positive the
companies are ran by 70 30 guys okay
they're ran by 70 30 and then they're
supported by 60 40 degrees interesting
I'll put that chart down in the
description what do you think you're at
this point in your life I'm a 70 30 guy
I'm a 70 30 guy I start off as a 90 10
guy I'm like I'm but it's just so good
and then I'm like yeah and I won 80 20
I'm like dude nobody around me is
winning I was 25 years old like hey no
no I'm not going to play this 80 20 game
then I want 70 30. and 70 30 you have to
bring people with you have to you have
to bring people with you but you still
have to drive you have to be in a tough
position to challenge everybody you're
going to be the guy that's going to be
the sometimes hate it disliked you're
raising the standards you're expecting
people push a little more that's not it
that's not the most ex most people want
to be number one but they do not want to
be number one yeah I mean they don't
want what comes with the territory but
to go back to this on what we're talking
about listen guys
what is fresh and fit done you guys have
helped a lot of
young men uh guys like yourself guys
like uh Tate you know you got your show
sauce cast all of these different things
is getting single men who feel they're
alone and they're weak and they can't do
anything and no one's talking to them no
one's flirting with them you're giving
them you're empowering them right on
what to do perfect so then you have to
know that value is that a value that
benefits a 16 year old a 22 year old a
28 year old does it also benefit a 38
year old a 48 year old a 58 year old I
don't know so that that's the part that
we have to be thinking about because
eventually like for me
um
you know okay so you your life is done
with I ask this guy the question I said
I said Adam you died today what's your
legacy what are people saying at your
funeral is it the guy was cooked with
the ladies dog no one gives a
nobody yeah I'm telling you no one gives
a yeah do it the guy was freaking
good with money no one gives a the
guy was so funny
verses
siamak my brother-in-law his father died
so his father was a Walter Cronkite of
Iran
his funeral 2500 people show I think
they did three funerals that's how big
the helicopters everything Rye is
protesting because it was a very big
name man he won the best voices in Iran
Allah Imani
so
Mac is there so proud of him
walking around like a boss taking care
of his family
but he says so many people came to me
and told me the things that my dad did
for them that I never knew about
he said the most emotional thing for me
was how many men came and said do you
really know who your dad was do you
really know who your dad was he says my
dad never bragged about what he did for
other people but everybody kept coming
there's nothing like when I go around
other men that have known my dad for a
while and they tell me what my dad did
for them there's nothing like it there's
nothing like it at the end of the day
that's what it's going to come down to
at your funeral either they're going to
say this guy smashed so many he made a
lot of money or freaking a this guy
changed our life and especially so many
that no one knows about it's by far the
best stories when people say things like
that so you know uh uh I think it's
important to realize that if we can lead
from the 70 30 side come down from the
90 10 the 80 20 to the 70 30 side and
you can kind of start seeing that hey I
need to drive but I also need to be
looking at this way as well and I need
to kind of invest in things that outlive
me if you and I start looking at things
that outlive us life changes I'll say
this final thoughts and I'll just kind
of turn it over to you guys marriage is
risky staying single is riskier
having kids is risky
being childless is riskier okay
believing in God is risky not believing
in God is riskier
being part of a startup is risky taking
the safe route is riskier making
investment is risky not making any
Investments is riskier so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign